are all bold and I am pro-way programs safe for all tri-vestors of pregnancy.
I would say absolutely. We have people that use over the years of doing rife for the last
27 years of doing rife. We've had people do the rife to get pregnant to help themselves
help get pregnant. We had people do the rife to try to help hold their pregnancy. The people
were common miscarriages, having common miscarriages. There's no contra-indications to using frequencies.
There's contra-indicative frequencies but none of those are in the any of the rife programs,
obviously. I'm not saying that using another rife machine where you can put in a specific frequency
could that be harmful possibly? Are any of the programs on the true rife dangerous
for pregnancy? No, I would say not. Especially if you're running your cancer programs.
If you have cancer and get pregnant, I think it proves you to continue using your cancer
programs. The issues that you have with cancer and pregnancy are a little unique because
during your pregnancy, your immune system shifts, especially during your second trimester,
your immune system shifts to a TH2 dominance. What that means is that so I understand your
immune system is the simplest explanation. You have a killer side and a side that makes antibodies.
So the killer side is part of the TH1 side. The side that makes antibodies is part of the TH2 side.
So your body, the way God made you, it is inputted wisdom. He doesn't want your body to recognize
the fetus as an enemy because the fetus is not you. Here's a good argument for
my body against my body, my choice. Well, I guess it supports my body, my choice.
Yeah, your body, your choice, but the fetus is a separate body. Your body knows that because it's,
it fires a TH2 reaction through your entire second trimester and tell your third trimester
where your immune system doesn't have the capability and destroyed the fetus at that size.
And your third trimester, the fetus is large enough that your immune system would never be able to
injure it, but because it's a separate organism, it's a separate person growing inside you,
your immune system automatically shifts to a TH2 dominance. So your TH1 killer side won't damage
the fetus. Is that amazing? So that's how all women's bodies work. You have a pregnancy,
one set pregnancy, a baby attaches, that fertilized ovum attaches, and your body will start to shift
to a TH2 dominance to protect that new person inside of you. So because remember what your immune system
does, it kills foreign invaders. So it could easily sense this growing other human inside you as a
foreign invader. So your body shifts to a TH2 dominance so it peaks in the second trimester.
So the issue that with cancer is that you could end up with a TH1 deficiency during the second trimester
and theoretically and practically the cancer could start to grow a more because your your immune your
killer side of your immune system is being suppressed in order to protect the fetus. So using the
right at that time is even going to be more important because your immune system is going to be as
effectively killing cancer cells.